okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS here
from order flows.com and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Tuesday
February 21st 2017 and today did not
disappoint the day after President's Day
and we rallied some more um even got a
late rally again uh in the afternoon
first before we get started brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor risk
Capital can be risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
One Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk Capital should be used for trading
only those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results so the tools use in this
presentation is orderflow Traders you
know the orderflows trader with you know
my own analysis thrown in um you know
you could have a footprint chart but if
you don't know what you're looking at
what's the point of having a footprint
chart to trade with you know that's
that's one of the big mistakes a lot of
people make is that they think um you
know getting a footprint chart is the
way to go but I mean that's only part of
it you know you have to it's a tool
footprint charts are are tools and you
have to know what you're looking at and
you have to know what to look for um
I've also got a few other indicators in
here the the volto flip the U-turn and
the transition yes they're named after
me um you know they're my proprietary
indicators and you know they all deal
with reading orderflow in different ways
Okay so
uh you know without further Ado let's
get
started all right so first up this is
the e- mini three range chart and you
know we ended up higher for the day
obviously you know expectations for more
F fiscal stimulus and you know some
changes in regulations continue to know
feed these gains in that you're seeing
in the stock market you know the Dow was
up I think half a percent and you know
oil was a ended up a little bit
higher you I think it was at 54 bucks
Gold's kind of steady but you know when
you come into this morning today it been
pretty quiet since the the
European open I mean even though we're
trading near our highs you know coming
into the session you basically you know
the overnight low is like
49 and you know coming into 8 8:30 when
the cash opens 8:30 you know you're
looking at 54 and a quarter you know was
was your high before that um you know we
hit a new high just before the cash open
at 55 so you're talking basically a five
or six point range um you know from
basically from the European open till
now and it was pretty quiet but you know
if you're watching you saw when we hit
that high there at
828 there about um you know we got that
Divergence so you got the new high with
the negative Delta and you know you're
starting to come off but you're coming
off right ahead of the cash open um you
know I I did think that you know maybe
we catch a bid once the cash opens and
you know we started coming around you
know why I why I thought that is you
know President's Day you know it's one
of those patriotic holidays you know as
long as there's nothing negative coming
out in the world um you know people tend
to come in you know after these long
weekends and you know if there's nothing
negative um you know I think they'll be
buying so you know we did rally we made
a new high so at 828 you know you got a
new high you got a D
Divergence came in here you know started
making new highs just about 5 minutes
after the cash got another Divergence
835 boom right here and you got a ratio
which again is kind of you know which
normally you would think is going to be
bearish right you got a A Divergence
you've got a ratio point of control up
near the high these two bars as we
started making these highs you know in
intra bar you know were flashing
divergences because they did have uh Min
Deltas you know 500 here 300 so you know
at one point in the bar the Delta was
negative and you know we're busting to
new highs so we're flashing some
divergences there so you know coupled
with this new high at 828 with the
Divergence you know then I started
seeing some Divergence In and Out In and
Out In and Out in and out in the next
bar and then this bar prints a
Divergence and and it's at that point
thinking okay you know within you know 7
minutes we already got two divergences
you I want to wait and see you know
rather than just coming in and looking
for a a place to sell um again you know
I I don't usually come into the market
with a bias but um you know this this
morning I you know like I said there was
nothing really negative out there that's
going to affect the market
today from the weekend so you know
what's going to happen is the Market's
going to go up in my opinion and then
you started rallying here we got ratio
ratio ratio and this is three in a row
right here 1 two three that's what I
like to see you know what I was
expecting to see in this bar is a
pullback you didn't you got another
bullish
ratio now this is interesting in here
here you have you know negative Delta
right - 763 okay there's a couple ways
to read that um I won't get into them
but obviously at one point you had
another Divergence forming because you
know it's-
900 and it was you know towards late in
the bar that it spun around and settled
higher okay then you got three here I
was looking for a pullback in between
these two points of controls right when
I say you have this three in a row this
is bar one this is bar two this is bar
three look for a pullback usually in
this fourth bar here look for a pullback
in between these two points that
controls so
that's is that 36
and4 to 3 6 or sorry 36 56 and a quarter
to 56 and 3/4
okay ideally that's where your your
ideal entry would be okay now again take
things in context of where they are in
the market do you want to be buying near
a high well if you think the market is
going to go higher yeah of course or do
you want to be buying near a low
preferably I normally love to buy near
lows because I think you know I say I
like picking lows but I'm always looking
for those reversals um you know when
you're going to new highs especially new
contract highs highs lifetime highs you
never know what you know what's waiting
for you up up top um so you know take
that with the grain and solid but I've
already got this minor bias coming in
here and I've already got a couple
divergences printed um got one that you
know almost happened again here you know
if if this happened it would have ch we
would not have had this three in a row
but so what I normally look for is you
know this bar this fourth bar to be a
red bar in this case it's green all
right so you know what happens here this
is where you get the next this is where
you get your red bar but again what do
you got right you got another Divergence
this time you got a ratio bounds low
indicating some you know some volume up
here to sort of stop this move you can
see nothing traded here we hit this
level boom we sell off you got imbalance
here imbalance here
okay where did we trade down to in this
bar right we traded down to 56 and a
quar this point of control right I said
look for a pullback you know after this
three in a row what you're doing is
you're looking for a pull back in
between these bars here you know these
not these bars these point of controls
one two or in bar three point of control
and bar two point control and you this
in this case you did you pulled right
down to it you pulled right down to 56
and a quarter
okay next bar again it's bearish you got
a bearish ratio right
here strong negative
Delta okay what again this next bar it's
it's alternating now here you got
bullish ratio bearish ratio bullish
ratio bearish ratio bullish ratio
bearish ratio you after you get one two
three you know again at that point I'm
looking for the market to start going
sideways which it does you know when
you're getting alternating you know
bullish to bearish ratios bar after you
know consecutive bars 1 two three
already I'm starting to look for fourth
fifth six and I'm looking for it you
know basically to go sideways which it
does here but again you know going back
to this one two three right your entry
for this setup is between these two bars
okay ideally I'd like this bar to just
be gone you know that'll make this
analysis a lot easier you get this bar
here it's red down here you get the
pullback right there um in this case it
just takes a long way here and then we
start popping back up again now you the
other thing to notice right here you
have another Divergence so going back to
uh here 828 you've got one
Divergence right 828 835 another one
841 so it's already you know 828 841 is
at 13 minutes you've already got three
divergences um what happens right so we
start going up got another Divergence
right here 847 So within 20 minutes 19
minutes you've already had four
divergences and you know on trending
markets you're going to
get multiple divergences often times
there's going to be a group of them
early right and you know that's what you
want to be alert for so you could have
you know put two and two together one
with these divergences already happening
here you know this is already your your
third one but again you know you can see
you had one that was forming in here you
had one earlier um forming in here if
when you're watching the market you can
see
it and then you got the three in a row
you got the pull back right in there and
it's you know to me that's just you know
very clear it's just Off to the Races so
you know if you're looking you know be
buying anywhere you know say you don't
want to take this three in a row you
know the the divergences themselves gave
it away you know there is a great buying
opportunity around the 57 58 area and
then we just proceed to keep going
higher right more Divergence that fails
you know it comes right back you know
what you don't want is you know a
Divergence you know in a ratio then the
next bar is this you know a bullish
ratio right after
that then you just go higher and then
you know again another one here you know
you're just St stepping up higher higher
higher you get all the way up to
64 and this is 924 you
get get a little bit of a pullback in
there you come in here make this new
high here at 943 you got a stack buying
imbalance you come up here to 64 and
3/4 got a Divergence got a ratio you
know ratio after that then another um
you know another ratio here but look at
this highs right you got all these
negative Deltas 1500 2,000 600 you know
these are small 600 200 2200 you at this
point you're thinking okay maybe this
can be the high all right why because
you got
right up on the high very strong
negative Deltas you know 1500 2,000 here
2,200 now why would I say that there and
I didn't say it back here well this is
kind of strong here you know 2100 1,000
8 is nothing minus 1,000 at this point
also I would be looking say Hey you know
maybe maybe this high is going to be the
high and it can hold we can sell off and
then you know we start coming
back in here you know it's just spinning
this Wheels gets kind of small here 200
300 you know these are kind of cancel
each other out um but obviously when you
get back in here and you take out that
high honly you know it's not far out of
the realm to be looking if you're
looking to get short off of this in here
at 9 this structure here at 924 to 930
um you there's nothing wrong with that
getting short in here somewhere around
60 62 61 and 1/2 you know with a stop up
here at at 3 and 1/2 um you know if if
cuz if you're going to take out this
High you know the whole reason for being
short is you know is shorten this high
so you're going to have your stop right
around this High you know either at the
high or tick above it or a tick below it
um obviously we came back started
creeping back up here this
Delta you know 2400 is quite strong then
you just pop right up here with this uh
stacked imbalance so obviously you're
going to take out the High um but again
you know you do you want to risk two
points you know and and where's your
target going to be um you know it's
going to be down in you if you're
talking about getting short around 1 and
A2 two that area you know you should be
looking around um you know the 57s you
know so you could easily get you know
twice as much out of it than than what
you're
risking you know but even going back you
know some of these other ones you know
can can you be looking at Short of not
really there there's not enough you know
again I wouldn't want to be getting
short and on this one you know when I'm
staring at these very strong Deltas on
the way up 2,000 2000 4,9 00 and yeah
it's netive 1300 which is quite strong
but it's on the back of the strong
strong bind you know and when I see
that that's not what I like to be
getting short at I would rather be
getting short somewhere where it's like
here you know this one that didn't work
at least here you know the Deltas are
getting a bit smaller minus 5 is nothing
500 yeah it's almost I want say nothing
but it's it's not that strong I mean you
know 500 is is obviously not as strong
as two you know 1900 and
4,000 you so this one didn't work out
but you know so what you got up here is
quite
similar you know around the 64 and 3/4
with all this you know this negativity
so to speak you know you got your
Divergence you've got um you know one
two three ratios here you know this one
is is not but then you know again you're
sitting here you're staring at this at
this point in time you you got to make a
decision what should I do should I get
long or should I not get long should I
get short or you know sit out or we
going to go higher honestly you know at
this point in time I'm looking at this
thinking you know this we can sell off
from here it's not a bad area to be
getting short in um you know and so if
you could be getting short somewhere you
know you know this bar is up but you
know anywhere between you know when
you're looking at it at this time at
957 you know trying to pick an area to
get short in you know I don't know 63 62
and a half 6 anywhere between 2 and a
half to three and A2 would be fairly
decent this next bar comes in we trade
up to I think it was uh 3 and a quar and
then you get this bar here Pony control
right on the
high got a ratio bounds low indicating
some heavy volume up here so what you so
we'll think of what's going on here in
the psychology of the market you know we
hit the high start coming off okay
working your way back up all these price
action Traders right everyone says oh
you got to buy the pullbacks right
because we going to go higher well
that's what they're trying to do here
right they're trying to buy this
pullback but now you got you got some
resistance coming into the market you
see, 1400 traded here the offer even
went bid here at 3 and a qu so it was 3
and a qu 3 and A2 didn't trade three and
A2 cuz the three and you know guys at
three and a/2 or the sellers at three
and a quarter just came in and whacked
it back down you know they they hit the
bid turned it offer and you know trades
three trades 2 and 3/4 trades 2 and a
half and we just settled you know start
working your way down um you know from
there so you know the first time you
know back here at
924 you know yeah I I I think that's a
perfectly legitimate legitimate place to
get short it didn't work out okay you
got stopped out you took a loss okay
fine you know you look for the next the
next trade you know I I know like people
want to have every single trade that
they ever take to be winners but you
know that's not what trading is it's not
about being right 100% of the time it's
about being right you know more than
you're wrong and and preferably having
your winners be bigger than your losers
I mean you know people you
know the problem with a lot of Traders
is you know they they want to be right
all the time and because of that you
know they suffer um bigger losses
because they think that they always got
to be right that they they can't accept
the loss so they let their loss get
bigger and it just exacerbates the whole
problem
so you know it's it's one of those
things you know when I was on the floor
and I was learning the hand signals you
know this was just in a hand signal
class um I remember the guy Romy bracie
was was the teacher and you had to take
that class you need to advance your
Advance basically Advance your career
down there otherwise you'd be a a clerk
the rest of your life
but he say don't beat yourself up you
know you have a loss on a on a trade or
you make a mistake on an order entry or
something and you know just put it
behind you
and carry on you know get on you know
say you make a mistake okay cover you
know get on don't don't beat yourself up
over these things and you know that
that's what you got to do if you want to
be successful is okay take your loss
okay that's fine you know losses are
going to come and get on to the next
trade so you know if you're getting in
here around 2 and a half
three um you know you're kind of spun
around a little bit you know it's
trading one and a half you know two and
A2 you know then it starts you know then
it starts coming off here you know we
trate all the way down to uh you know s
what is that 7
3/4 you know even down here 7 and a half
you know then the selling starts coming
in here you see the selling really
trying to pick up
here you know Delta is getting stronger
557 600
2500 you know then we get down to this
56 so you know that's if you're getting
short at at two and a half you know 30
minutes later we're trading 6 and a half
that's six points right on the other
trade right you lost two points you know
so people always say oh you know I got
to have these trades it's got to be 4
to1 risk reward ratio I just laugh you
know because when when I I see that you
know it's usually by people that don't
necessarily trade and don't understand
that sometimes you know hey even if I
could get a tick out of a trade I'm
happy you know cuz you know for whatever
reason you know sometimes trades just
don't work out um you know you can't
predict what's what's going to be
happening in the
market so you know that was
really I I had a a dental a dental
appointment later so I missed what what
happened with the rest of these uh you
know with with the rest of the day I I I
did expect I say expected but you know
last week pretty much you know the last
hour hour and a half you'd get these
these late session rallies and again I I
was sort of in the back of my head you
know looking for um something like that
to happen again today and you know today
did not disappoint um you I'm going to
show you this Dow chart um yeah I love
this this mini da this 100 100 range
chart
um you know this is the so this is that
indic at the Vol transition you know
which I talk about here you know these
three indicators the flip U-turn and
transition and you know on the 100 the
100 tick chart it's sitting on
there you know settings is just 3 100
400 you know mini da you know before
Cash open you don't really bother with
it honestly um so here's Cash open here
841 gives a gives a nice Buy Signal so
this is around the uh you know 675 is
area I mean realistically you should be
getting along you'll let the market take
you in 680 trades all the way up up to
here you get a sell here but again it
doesn't sell off um you know this this
is one of the the things problems that
indicator Traders have is they think as
soon as they get a indicator fires off
they got to get short but you know let
the market take you in right if you're
getting a sell signal let the market
start to sell off just as here right you
get a Buy Signal let the market start
rallying get you
in you know so this one didn't work out
obviously but again you know did the
market take you in no it didn't right so
should you be taking it probably not
then you know I get up here get another
one it starts to come off a little bit
you know I don't know if it would have
gotten in i' like to see it a little bit
more rather than um one or two
ticks you know this one here you know
it's it didn't um you know even though
it did sell off I don't think you know
this was a decent one to take you know
it's it's selling get short here off in
this off this bar then the market just
rallies again I'm not waiting you know
this is how many how long how many
minutes before it starts selling off you
know even though it was nice this is
what you want right
here right you get the signal saying hey
get short Market sells off right from 05
down to O okay now you can get short you
know it's making its move you know what
you want you know when when a signal
kicks off right it you want it to be you
want the action to be fast you don't
want to be sitting around like here and
just you know let the market lope around
and then and then make its move you want
the move to happen very fast and this is
it you know so say you're getting in you
know say I mean unless you're quick
right I mean you could get programs out
there you know signal plus whatever you
know or signal minus whatever and it's a
nice move down you know I again another
one here you know this one yeah not
really I mean this one I don't think you
should have been taken you you don't
want me getting long and the bar comes
right down on you like that here
1050 I don't know even though is nice to
say yeah you should have taken it again
you know it it's starts up and then it
comes right back down you know that's
that's that's not what you want you know
what you want is the move to be
happening you know in the next bar
dramatically not like this yeah kind of
half-hearted up a little bit you know
this one you definitely don't want to be
taken right it if you're getting a short
signal here right you should be waiting
looking in the next bar let it come off
right if it starts rallying going up
don't think hey I'm getting a better
entry no you're not you're getting a
worse entry because it's probably going
to be going against you
this one yeah you probably go to taken
and you know maybe taken a small
loss same thing here um you know this
one yeah it started too you know maybe
you could have managed that for a for a
little bit of a scratch
uh you know this one you shouldn't have
been taken this one I mean
again this getting back to you know the
Market's been putting in these rallies
late in the day you we're coming up on
3:00 you know over here now we had just
rallied for from
basically okay what I'm getting at is is
this okay so 1049 you got this this low
here all right you make this move all
the way up here do you want to be taking
along when you just rallied from six you
know 660 all the way up to 720 do you
want to be getting long again no you I
don't you I like to think things in
context right not when you're up here
near the highs busting through new highs
do you want to be getting
long I I I don't find that very um you
know very high percentage trade and then
late in the day again you know right
after the cash close again I don't
Advocate I mean you can trade after the
cash close it's volume is is thinner but
people are still trading it it's quite
active um you know this this a quick one
um you know basically you know 05 down
to 690 so it's quick 15 ticks but
um yeah so that's that's the that was
the transition there on that that mini d
you know just real quick let's take a
look at a couple
other this is the euro currency wasn't
much in the euro currency today it's
pretty quiet um again you know this is
3: in the morning um this is 9 yeah it's
not really going anywhere El probably
would scratch you know late I I'm not a
big fan of trading eurocurrency after 2
o'clock anyway you know 2 o'clock
Chicago time is 3:00 New York time and
you know pretty much
everyone's I'll say everyone but uh you
know most people cash dealers are
looking to go out and get blasted
already get drunk so this was the bonds
okay transition is 987 tick
chart and gives you one signal one
signal today and look at that right off
the
low and look at that that's almost
that's a th Point move right there I'm
not saying that you would have bought it
here and sold it up here honestly you
know if I was in this trade you know and
I'm looking in here at 848 you know for
me the bonds I'm really only looking for
five or six ticks realistically I'm I'm
happy with that you know I I don't hit
home runs in the bonds uh you know I I
have my profit targets so this one you
know it would have been met but uh you
know that that that's a nice move again
I'm not I'm not one of these people
saying oh yeah look he could have got uh
you know 26 ticks out of this
move I mean be be realistic even though
it's if the signal gave it right here
yeah I might be a little bit more apt
but you know even if I was long and I
sort of run into this I'd be looking to
get out at this you hey that's a nice
profit I would have just been happy to
take it and be done with it but um I
just that's me um you
the what else do I got here get some
other charts real
quick crw
right there we got 987 tick on the crude
or did I show The e- Minis 987 tick on
the e-
minis H there's a couple signals in the
987 tick you know why 987 tick well you
know a crude guy turned me on to 987
tick charts 987 is a fib
number and you know it's just one of
those things he says hey you should look
at 997 tick chart in ever since then
I've kept it up for the last couple
years
so here you got a sell this is the
transition again 300 400 this one you
know if you took it again I like to let
it sort of lead me into the trade this
one didn't work out you know say you got
short you know you would have been
stopped out but again you know let's you
know let's open it up a bit you know
this is like s and a quarter getting
there s and a half you know it it trades
down one tick now that's it you know at
least let it come down to 57 you know at
least half a tick you know ideally I
said you know let the market Lead You In
you know it's not it's not doing
anything you know it takes one tick
lower and that's it then turns around
and starts rallying um you know so is
that the best trade no um you know you
say if you took it you know where's your
stop you know your stops just going to
be up here you know 58 58 and a quarter
or something okay so you know you did
get one other
signal and then look here so you're get
in a buy okay the next bar it's nice you
know it's a nice
you know that's 8 and a
quarter right here it trades all the way
up to almost
nine you it comes back down to eight I
think in this one bar here so you know
if if you're getting you know it's
making a move so you know you say
getting in in at uh the high this this
bar ends up at uh 8 and a half so you
know you give it a half a tick get in at
9 okay so you don't you you want it to
trade through there you know you can put
a stop in whatever
you know you're risking one tick here I
mean you could obviously you could have
more rather than one tick one point
but you know it's starting to move in
the direction that you want it to go
right it's it's gone up from uh 8 and a
quarter up to to nine so it's already
know three qu three ticks it's
moved and then it trades all the way
back up to the highs you know up here at
uh 4 and 3/4 so you know you could have
got something at least out of that trade
there
uh that's the E
minis okay well I'll show the crude I I
don't I didn't look at the crude this
morning but uh what you have anything
I'll go back here so this is again this
is the transition this buy again it
doesn't go any higher than the bar this
bar here it goes here so this high is
what 79 is 80 you know do you want to
get high get get into a trade one tick
no you know just as here right it gets
one tick you know 71 trades down to 70
and it sort of goes sideways on
you at least this one
here you know 60 comes all the way down
you know three ticks to 37 even the next
bar down to uh 56 you know again it's
it's up to you if if you know if you
want to
use I think you should use more more
than one tick not
just you know getting long getting short
off of off the the low of this bar take
the low plus a few ticks so you know
even if you're getting long here at this
low getting short rather at at six you
know it it comes all the way back up to
66 that's 10 ticks right against you
before it makes that move from 56 down
to you know down to the 30s
uh what
else I got some D charts here I don't
know this is what is this this is the
flip um is there anything on the
flip
no that's the Dow that's the flip five
and 25 settings
um let's just quickly see if there's
anything else
okay the
U-turn so this is the other one of the
other indicators right the U-turn here
well those U-turn um getting I'm showing
them on normal bar charts just for E of
use it's easier to see
it uh where's my
chart okay so urn here so three and
500's the
settings so okay I'm not going to talk
about this you know overnight there um
it's basically from you know 8:00 so
here you get a couple signals these
don't work out you know it pops up a
little bit comes right back down so
you're getting stopped out stopped out
if you're even getting into this first
one second one you probably would have
gotten into so you least you're getting
stopped out
there then look
it here right the market takes you
in comes back but then it comes right
back so again I'm not saying you would
have been buying it here down here at
the low no you should be buying it
somewhere in here you know this area of
what is that 7 7 and a quarter somewhere
in there you know your stop would be
below this
bar you know so below 56 so you know
you're risking a a point point in a half
and you see it just it shoots all the
way up to 60 right away comes back down
get another Buy Signal here so again you
don't I mean if you got out up here get
another buy signal in here it's giving
you the the signs that you know it could
go higher you know the next bar is up
even though it turns down doesn't get
below this bar you got this double
bottom here which is good you know last
thing you want is if were to make this
new swing low here then take off because
you'd be stopped out i' be looking at
getting stopped out and then again you
know from 58 you know you be
realistically 58 and A2 that area 58 and
3/4 you should be getting along and then
just right back up to the
highs and then you you drop off quite
sharply so
you know thanks for watching this video
um it's already gone 30 minutes but uh
if you want to learn more about the
trading software used in this
presentation and the
indicators and how you can profit from
orderflow Trading visit my website
orderflows dcom you know I I you say you
already have a orderflow footprint chart
that's fine you know I have a trading
course you know you can pick up some
extra tips in um you know if you want to
get my software you could you can get it
there on the site
uh I just reopened my my trading room
today I I took a break from it um you
know I I was honestly I was looking to
close it but then you know a lot of
people emailed me asking me to keep it
open you know and those are people that
have been with me for you know some of
them for a couple years already you I I
don't charge for that it's it's free for
users so as long as you you know are a
user as long as you buy the software
it's a onetime fee you get access to the
trading room um I don't cut you off
least you know it doesn't run every day
it runs uh Tuesday Wednesday Thursdays
but you know from 8:00 a.m. to 10:00
a.m. you know but it's a place where you
could see me um you know reading the
order flow so you could would have seen
me earlier in the day calling the e-
minis explaining it as it's happening so
anyway visit our website orderflows
thatcombines that there's one that's
been posted so thanks and hope to see
see you on the inside bye-bye